i really trippin as long as these racks
ain't slipping you know what i'm saying
jubilee
[Applause]
this is my friend lily we met in college
we attend college this is izzy
and the fun fact that came to my mind
was that she wore a duct tape dress to
improv nationals which i think is pretty
cool because she made it herself at the
end of the day we're both pretty open to
most people and like what matters is a
level of empathy and the ability to
listen i think that's something that
like holds true for us i don't know if
i'm talking to a girl one of the few
first few words
that comes out her mouth is empathy i
get like instantly soft it's just like
whenever she has in her profile
her pronouns
yeah yeah
it's like from talking to a girl one of
the first few things just like
intersectionality i'm like oh my god
here we go yeah you know what i'm saying
i don't know what it is
it's like
why do you have to mention empathy yeah
if you're an empathetic person we'll
just come on your behavior it's like a
dude going up to women like i'm a nice
guy ladies get turned off by that a lot
of the times i'm a super nice guy don't
shut the [ __ ] up you don't have to say
it yeah it's like a [ __ ] saying
he's rich all the time [ __ ]
you don't need to
hi guys
it's a lot of people
my hands are clammy but like in a cute
way yeah
there's nothing
let me just tell you guys there's
nothing cute about climbing hands i had
this one girl who just swept through her
palms like the way [ __ ] sweat at a
basketball court pickup game you think
what i'm saying yes
yeah yeah yeah like when her hands were
slappy i'm like damn that was wet
why would you slap me with her wear
hands
if you guys enjoyed today's video leave
a like and a comment because imagine you
just go to grab someone's hand and it's
just moist
clam
there's like even a little bit of
suction when you let go it's just clam
yeah so all people out there with clammy
hands
i know it only happens when you start to
get nervous most of the time um and so
if you're feeling uh targeted by this i
am targeting you and hopefully you're
just sitting on your phone they're like
oh my god
probably drop their phone on their hands
because
on a ideal first date it'll probably be
like a beach day you know have like a
little picnic on the way here we noticed
that there was an outback yeah the
steakhouse yeah the steakhouse
i'm vegetarian and she's vegan oh well
then this
might not right now but then no
no
i could have seen i could have seen
these two girls being vegan and
vegetarian i could have bet on it no we
can work with it we were thinking that
we would check in first on yelp mm-hmm
get that free blooming onions right
and then maybe ask for some
vegan options i guess i like the
planning though yeah i think
that was not a good thing yeah you're
definitely but they said they're less
[ __ ] tone because they're empathetic
and they're kind right so they're going
to reject you but they're not going to
let you see it because they're not going
to be that harsh to mine already but if
it was a white man who doesn't love
being blindsided it's much better when
you just say kind things get people's
hopes up and then dash it away at the
last second love that
it'd be fun if we went to a show we're
both musicians so you could come to our
show what music do you play we say cyber
for very cyber did they say cyber cyber
what's that i have no [ __ ] clue bruh
i'm not know what i'm not gonna do
look it up carry on but i will
[Music]
i'm feeling unstable
but i can never change though
life's been getting painful
boom
you imagine those cyber guys were like
you want to bang to my music
you do i just hear like the sounds of
robots just me like we love the future
the future isn't female it's machines
like you just imagine you're trying to
bring to that for our first day we would
take you to either a concert if you're
feeling up to it a music festival and we
would just dance the night away yeah and
maybe after we could go to like a
karaoke bar we could dance the night
away he's gonna dance like this
guys come with some hallmark energy i
can't hate
everybody that says dance the night away
don't dance
that's true that's true
then we go to the beach and then
something we like to do is uh stroll
around ikea i've never been to ikea
i just wish they would have invited some
like hood [ __ ] to be like listen man
you smoke weed
and that's a wrap
we take you flying to napa valley
because he has a private pilot's license
and then we're gonna go to a vineyard
over there and i'm a musician and i'm a
film major so we can play some music we
can
do some you know cute videos i'm gonna
take you my helicopter and drop you off
somewhere random and murder you like
don't do it it's a first date why are
you trying to isolate these people into
a random place y'all be doing hella
extra how would me and you
go with them huh let's just just we're
in the lineup and we go to them let's
see in front of us let's do it let's do
it in front let's let's do it let's do
it let's do it
so
i'm not [ __ ] why am i here
yo
i'm not interested no no
i'm not interested first off if you
think i'm gonna sign myself up with 20
other dudes to compete for two women
okay you are a buggy listen linda
you don't want to be like these
contestants and be eliminated in the
dating life clean skin is the first
thing that people see when they meet you
your business card your money maker your
wow factor you want to have clean skin
and t henley has a thing for you if you
feel a bit lost with this you don't know
where to start it's okay th henley has a
level one skin care system in that
system you have instruction that gives
you the frequency what products to use
the when the how you don't even have to
think evp lemon squeezy face cleaning
that's what it is so order your skin
care system today by th handling the
level 1 skin care system includes
products such as a daily face wash
because ain't nobody got time to walk
around with dirt and grime on their face
also the daily facial moisturizer that
has spf
20 on it because you don't want to burn
your skin out there skin cancer is a
real thing and the two times per week
scrub facial scrub
to get all the little particles out of
your pores so if you're ready to have
clear skin go in the link in the
description below and order your box and
you'll get a free gift on us
it's really me all right it's not really
yabba it's really me because i'm the
skincare guy right you're on your way to
clean skin and you got a gift boom
okay i'm a little scared of planes
so i don't know if i could do the clean
date
[Music]
it was a little short-lived but it's
definitely unfortunate
see i'm mad
man too much to say honestly i think
before i never had a best friend i'm
telling you that i think as guys many
times when i'm authentic with each other
right i think for us that's something
that's really valuable you want to just
build each other up and he does a good
job of just encouraging me with his
thoughtfulness his caring his kind heart
thanks matt
i would honestly call this man a
visionary and a dreamer he wants to make
a change and a positive impact um
uh albert doesn't give a [ __ ] about
y'all
how would i introduce preach
how did you just preach don't
this [ __ ] petty as [ __ ]
this [ __ ] got a wife
this thing got a wife so i'll take the
both of y'all you did what i'm saying
listen i'll get one two or three and i
just grabbed the other one you feel me
huh elizabeth where you at
i'll take all three
because you got a wife no you won't what
you mean i want you why wouldn't i take
one three you don't
[ __ ] cause this has there ever been a
[ __ ] time where you believed in me
bro bro bro i'm gonna tell you why why
because this is internet and they're two
white girls
that's true
some of the [ __ ] up put your chest
down calm down that's you've been saying
that [ __ ] so stop don't it's not even a
beef or whatever he's not he's not even
alive i can never i can never handle two
white girls publicly
but behind closed doors yeah yeah i hope
so
listen i said
you're right i apologize yeah yeah he's
also a visionary and he's like produces
music his dj's like all around the world
he's extremely talented produces music
and dj's too not around the world but
around the city
he really will like he's binge abby
i like how like it's always the less
attractive dude who's always selling the
thing yeah the more attractive guy just
stands there like i know what my strong
suit is yeah
[Laughter]
ugly dudes know how to sell [ __ ] because
they've been trying to sell themselves
their whole life
will allow you to see the world in a
different way allow you to hear things
differently and it kind of changes your
perspective on how you see people and
how you see the world
so basically this guy is
[Laughter]
this mushrooms
this dude is shrooms
am i wrong though have you ever seen the
joe rogan experience
mushrooms
that's what he said in the whole
description
how do you feel about nature
mushrooms
do you want to go to space chrome
[Laughter]
he's got like this fly hair and a cool
grill he's got hella views on youtube
the artist and he's super loyal he's
from florida and i don't know if it's
because he's from florida he's got that
southern hospitality you point to the
left i'll point to the right okay okay
two one
it was cool it didn't take it too hard
to take it personally you know yeah i'm
really tripping as long as these racks
ain't slipping you know what i'm saying
[Music]
pop
i so badly don't want to be that old
geezer but you know the truth
you are i am that old geezer
you know what killed me about this the
only bars is this one is
this is this goofball brought money to
this thing
the show is racks
press play god damn god damn yeah next
time i get rejected by a girl i'm gonna
do that too i'll just start pulling up
[ __ ] i ain't hurt i'ma just skirt
feel like really
[Music]
hello again hello hello
wow hi again hello hello meet again are
you guys both from california oc yeah
california orange county so southern
california born and raised asian and
from orange county like what are the
odds that
one of these two
but if you probably ask this
[ __ ] to airflare he'd be like
he just starts going at it what grade
are you in where are your dreams we're
both juniors
and you're majoring in we're about
business
oh my gosh okay nice thing okay
majoring
business wow capitalism all right cool
we're more of a socialist so we don't
know how we feel about business majors
you imagine looking at two chinese
students and just being like how do you
feel about the hammer and sickle you
know if vegans had a flag it would be a
hammer sickle and some quinoa in the
background i read a lot
and uh hang out with this guy a lot so
we both do those things sometimes yeah
yeah like read books right next to each
other in the same way
you read to each other
right you know what let me give a quick
shout out to the asians for winning
today yes there's a mexican but they're
spicy asians as preachers so it's really
for asian
you gotta throw people
in the bus like that though no because
you said it yeah but i said it a while
ago yeah but i'll bring it back because
i don't forget what you say the same way
you don't forget what i say oh what am i
sexy no how many times did you call me
on this elizabeth stuff
because it is what it is yeah yeah well
you know what they spicy it is what it
is
okay there it is though
shout out to the asians because y'all
don't get enough love in these dating
shows you always get booted so i'm glad
today that you were chosen and to be
chosen by white women i'm sure is a
great honor for you so congratulations
i think we would go as the way we're
sitting
correct
possibly yeah
oh my god
that was like agreeing without agreeing
you understand what i'm saying she
basically said oh so i get stuck with
the other oh a word oh i get the ugly
one possibly sure
[ __ ] here's the thing if it was man we
would have been like all right i'm
taking one for the team ladies black
because they're both competing for the
same dude yeah it is let's just tell you
what you said yeah that's exactly what
you said yeah we really want to stress
just a stress-free day for you guys so
we would like hit you guys up the night
before give you some itinerary but it's
still loose you know and then yeah like
we said we want to accommodate you guys
and so the asian guy is definitely not
feeling them no the attractive one no
he's like [ __ ] to you i'm a k-pop star
yeah yeah i'm good
kim soo yoon loves me
why would i [ __ ] with you like we
chillin
vegetarian a vegan go to your favorite
place
veggie grill and we're also just so
spontaneous he's just sitting on why am
i here
keep talking i'm gonna i got a whole
k-pop fan base that would suck my dick
at any point
ah i gotta go home and work on my dance
moves jesus christ my agent said it was
good for me oh my god it's not recent
development in our lives includes going
to the local court and playing something
that like
resembles pickup basketball with each
other how would you guys feel about that
basketball
this guy has an insane hook shot yeah my
skyhook is actually no way
who's getting picked
uh spicy spicy asian or straight asian
spicy i think it's gonna be straight i
don't think the mexicans making it on
the lineup it's possible all right so
yeah
okay three two one two two
i was gonna say two but you set it
before me but i was back
cause this [ __ ] didn't look he
looked so disinterested at some point
yeah yeah that it's like those ladies
are like yeah we're gonna go do a
basketball game right and that guy's
gonna be doing sky hooks and then
they're gonna sneak off and do a
threesome
i think that's hypothetically what's
gonna be possible honestly i thought we
were gonna be eliminated immediately
when you said you're vegetarian vegan
but it was like funny like you guys
carried on the bank right i'm not
vegetarian
i eat
[Laughter]
shout out to the guy who said nothing
and pulled both the girls yeah shout out
to him
he carried this team yeah
and that's what mattered and i don't eat
there that often i really don't it's
okay it's okay if you do if you guys
want to exchange numbers
i'm down i'm not gonna say we're done
sure
okay i mean okay yeah okay totally cool
what are your thoughts man
that was beige yeah they were they were
kind of basic it wasn't interesting that
was beige it was like you know nothing
spicy it was gap yeah you know yeah gap
yeah yeah yeah i am mad at mount zafra
yeah so after you know all these [ __ ]
nah i see what you're saying all right
see y'all they call me mellow yellow